wenn ich allerdings jetzt mal hier vorne
hin laufen hier in kryta draufsetzen den
mal anzünde geht nur die steinplatte
kaputt auf der stadt
hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer weiteren
folge von in minecraft heute am mittwoch
weil gestern dienstag war und ich es
nicht geschafft habe wegen der
hundertsten folge hero aber was ihr seht
ich habe mich ein bisschen die welt
gesetzt und habe diesen ganz klein
bisschen verändert und zwar einfach
defekt so mittlerweile neu aufgebaut und
das ganze so ein bisschen naja
miteinander verbunden weil ich einfach
gestern ein bisschen langeweile hatte
und kann nicht mehr aufnehmen konnte
dann habe ich einfach ein bisschen alle
welt gebastelt
aber ich würde erstmal sagen wir fangen
direkt an und zwar der erste effekt
würde mir zugesendet von simon was sie
hier schon seht ist hier meine beiden
häuser gold und gold dies dass wir haben
hier ein paar holzplatten drin liegen
darunter zur demonstration haben wir
erde also gras und hier runter haben wir
zur demonstration auch gras so low
carbon zeigt uns dass und zwar ganz
einfach ihr wisst ihr einen krieg stellt
schaden an das heißt zum beispiel in den
kriterien nicht sind die neben anderen
mit der explodiert ihr legt er macht
schaden er hat jetzt hier drei erde und
fünf von diesen komischen platten kaputt
gemacht wenn ich allerdings jetzt mal
hier vorne hin laufen hier in creeper
draufsetzen den mal anzünde geht nur die
steinplatte kaputt oft er erstand ich
kann auch mal von mir aus hier was
gibt's denn hier noch so fürs letzte mal
war gucken ihre kleider und brixen
brixlegg ist ja auch stein mehr oder
weniger so setzt mal drauf ich kann
nicht sagen nur die steinplatte geht
kaputt und nur die brigg also die brigg
platte ist kaputt gegangen
wenn ich allerdings erzieherin prima
drauf setzte dann wäre das ganze hat
nicht so cool
jeder direkt ein bisschen mehr kaputt
ist das ganze ein bisschen anders wenn
ich den krieg hier drauf setzte also
neben diese komische andere wand klappt
das ganze nämlich auch das ist nämlich
auch ganz geil und zwar einfach wenn die
kripo auf einer steinplatte steht geht
nichts kaputt außer die steinplatte die
man teilweise sogar bekommt also seht
jetzt hier da habe ich jetzt nicht
bekommen aber hier habe ich zum beispiel
bekommen und wenn dirk riepe irgendwo
anders drauf steht dann geht's halt
kaputt und das fake nummer eins und
dafür danken sieht man das auf jeden
fall cool wenn man ein haus baut einfach
aus diesen steinplatten und ist gar
nichts kaputtgehen und fake nummer zwei
wurde mit zugesendet von wandel per mail
an contractor gmail.com wo eben auch weg
finden senden könnt und auch in die
kommentare schreiben also schreibt mal
auch alles in die kommentare liegt das
video auch bewerten wenn es euch bisher
gefällt also das könnt ihr alles machen
das ist mega cool und zwar ist das ja
eigentlich ganz witzig wenn man sich
vorstellt dass minecraft immer
realistischer werden möchte dann ist es
zum beispiel so wenn ich von einer
klippe springen und mir zum beispiel ich
weiß nicht mal völlig fälle jetzt hier
zum beispiel weil ich zwei drei herzen
oder so dann ist vielleicht wie bei
einbruch circa 0 3 herz ist für ein
drittel fiel also in etwa nur dann über
ort können schon beinbruch sein dann
sprinte ich natürlich nicht weiter
sondern bleibt eigentlich erst mal
liegen
und das wäre in minecraft auch ganz cool
was ich mir wünschen würde und zwar wenn
man von der klippe herunter fällt das
man vielleicht zwei sekunden liegen
bleibt weil man einfach dann verletzt
ist und danach generiert man sich wieder
und läuft dann erstmal wieder langsam an
das sind zu features die ich mir für die
1.8 wünsche in minecraft ist es
allerdings so wenn ich sprinte und ich
glaube auf eine klippe zu und weil dann
hier runter nicht läuft einfach weiter
ich habe dieses kreuz hierhin gemacht um
zu zeigen dass ich da auch wirklich
lande gleich das hier noch mal zeigen
kleine genau auf dem kreuzer okay ich
will wissen nicht so mittig gelaufen
aber naja das ist wieder so luca
langeweile dingsbums so warte durch
komische so zu laufen so das heißt die
sprinter putzig lande und ich laufe
einfach weiter also das liegt nicht an
diesem kreuz oder so da kann noch andere
blöcke seien aber ich laufe einfach
weiter und ich bin halb und das ist
eigentlich ein ganz cool effect und das
will ich mir wünschen für kommende
version dass man dann vielleicht kurz
liegen bleibt oder so kann man ja mal
mit dem smart movie award verbinden das
wäre bestimmt auch ganz gut so der
dritte effekt wurde mir zugesendet von
enea und zwar mein team das wenig über
diese dinge über laufe das dann nix
passiert also wenn ihr das mal ihr euch
hier anschauen
ich stehe eigentlich relativ warte jetzt
erst mal so ich stehe eigentlich relativ
in der mitte von dem blog so warte mal
mehr mehr mit ich kann ich nicht stehen
so und jetzt läuft sich auf dieses loch
da hinten zu und ich laufe da direkt
rüber und ich laufe einfach über dieses
loch drüber also das ist das klappt zu
einer prozent chance von sagen wir mal
10 prozent also ich habe das früher ein
paar mal getestet hat immer
aufgeschrieben und das jetzt klappt oder
nicht jetzt zum beispiel klappt es die
ganze zeit beim zehnten mal jetzt selbst
zum beispiel hat wenig grad reingefallen
also es klappt nicht immer aber
hingefahren sind jetzt klappt zum
beispiel gerade auch nicht schräg
darüber laufen
aber wer zum beispiel so hierüber laufe
es klappt also ich kann halt einfach so
überlaufen auch wenn ich noch so mit ich
klicke ihr seht dass ich bin direkt mit
licht vom blog ich habe meine vier
weitere entfernungen damit das wirklich
so ich laufe mit ich auf das ding zu
gucken gerade aus und schaffe es
wirklich direkt rüber zu laufen da sieht
doch super witzig aus ja okay das wieder
schräg okay und ich laufe auf das ding
zu und der vorführeffekt meine lieben
freunde so rannte los jetzt ihr vorhin
also ich hab wirklich errechnet zehn
prozent dass ich da halt nicht rein
falle so wenn ich jetzt ruhiger läufer
also ich glaube halt wirklich direkt
darüber ich versuche hier mal so mit ich
jetzt nicht wieder eingefallen aber ihr
habt es glaub ich gesehen und ihr wisst
was ich meine
es besteht nämlich eine bestimmte chance
dass man über sonne noch hier einfach
überlaufen kann das hat jetzt auch
wieder gesehen jetzt auch wieder
ich kann ja echt einfach immer so
überlaufen teilweise so jetzt auch und
das ist halt echt mega krass das ist
also es besteht eine 10 prozentige
chance dass sie über so ähnlich
einfach überlaufen könnte ohne dass sie
dar einfalt kommen wir zum fun fact wo
hier wiederum helden werden der fun fact
checker nicht witzig aber es geht mich
heute darum zwar hat mir das gamer
gamers pro lp geschrieben oder gamer
bros
gamepro lpg und zwar wurden die kripo
nur aus einem programmfehler geboren das
sollten eigentlich nämlich schweine
werden und auf einmal explodierten diese
schweine hatten dachte nämlich so sollen
ob der explodiert wenn man die angreifer
ist bestimmt auch ganz cool geht mit dem
einfachen anderen namen an der textur
und andere form und alles hinter mir ist
einfach creeper also dieser krise
schweinen sollte eigentlich dieser
creeper sollte eigentlich erst das hier
werden einschalten und wenn man das so
miteinander vergleicht nee nee passt
wirklich nicht also ich finde es auf
jeden fall cool das liquid dazu gekommen
sind weil es wurden so viele coole mir
schon immer schon mit prima gemacht und
reaper sind einfach bekannt für
minecraft und so was alles diesem ops
die halt wirklich nicht einfach nur
kämpfen sondern die halt wirklich
explodieren also ich find's ganz cool
und ich würde sagen dass war es auch
jetzt eigentlich wieder mit dem
minecraft effekt wenn es euch gefallen
hat las eine bewertung da bitte bewertet
das video einfach ob es euch gefallen
hat oder nicht einfach einen daumen hoch
oder daumen runter lassen und sonst
schreibt e-mails an konkreter die
mail.com oder in die kommentare und dann
will ich sagen sehen uns beim nächsten
mal wieder macht rein ich glaube nach
hätte ja nachher kommt auf